[Music]
[Applause]
if you uh have been with us on this show
we know you know that we have some uh
temporary hosts who come in fill in and
uh one of the people that uh i sought
out myself glenn ordway a long longtime
boston radio host for w-e-e-i for over
30 years and had always had great
respect for him he was a radio voice of
the celtics and an afternoon host at
w-e-e-i for about 34 years had his last
show yesterday on the radio and i
thought you know what there aren't many
of us left who've been doing this a long
time and have great respect for w-e-e-i
and certainly glen ordway and uh glenn
joins us now glenn uh how did you come
up with the decision to call it a career
well first of all thank you very much
dan and second of all hello to all the
danettes i miss you guys uh dearly
you know when you do it this long 48
years and you will come to this day
one day as well you sit there and say
you know how much life do you have left
do i want to go in there and do this
every single day i've got to watch four
games every single night you've got to
read everything prepare and i said i
still can keep my hand in it
do it
and yet i don't have to do it every
single day and they're giving me that
opportunity i ask for that opportunity
and it's perfect uh it's um and i'm
looking forward to the next challenges
here in my life so it's great yeah but
what are you gonna do when that big
story in boston breaks and
you're not on the radio to be able to
dive into it i haven't thought about
that yet come on i mean i'll find a way
of sneaking on the air i'll call as a
prank caller or something like that i'll
find a way to be able to do it because
you're right you can't you know
especially with boston and the emotion
of passion as you know of that town it
is hard to separate and i'm sure i'm
gonna have difficulty doing that but
we'll see how it goes biggest story
that you were around covered in the last
let's say 34 years boston see i would
tell you this if i were working in tampa
bay it would be very easy i could throw
one at you when you work in boston and
over the last 20 years with maybe the
greatest run a city has ever ever had of
winning teams it's hard to do 2004 red
sox go 86 years of failure without ever
winning came close couldn't win bucky
that we can go through all of these
different uh you know points in history
tamil 4 was pivotal it was unbelievable
the patriots as you know used to be a
disaster of a franchise 25 000 people
they had the worst attendance of any
team in the nfl in boston you couldn't
watch home games they were blacked out
look at them now i mean there's so many
different moments people have asked me
that question dan it's impossible to
pick one
but when they were down 3-0 to the
yankees
2004 everybody everybody was the you
know felt like the town was saying uh
once again another year they're done
they were done nine years we all thought
they were done we did and i would say
that is one of those moments one of
those pivotal moments you sit there and
you look back at you're down 3-0 and you
get blown out in that last game how the
hell are they going to come back yeah i
would say that might be one of the
biggest turnarounds and you tell me in
all of professional sports the history
of professional sports they were done
toast most important athlete
in your 34 years at ewei in boston um
this guy that is quarterback for the
tampa bay buccaneers right that was
pretty good okay how about i take him
out
i'm gonna take him
the greatest football player of all time
if you take him out
i would say then we're looking at larry
bird we're looking at bobby orr
does david ortiz get in there he does
but because he was a designated hitter
you probably view him a little bit
differently because he wasn't out there
in the field but as far as red sox
players go ted williams was a better
overall player than david ortiz david
ortiz had a bigger impact in boston as a
member of the red sox give me the
patriots story that you don't have the
full story on
um malcolm butler why did he not start i
can't tell you how many times we've
asked bill
uh that question and he won't reveal it
i've really come to the conclusion that
he had everything to do with football
and it had nothing to do with anything
else i mean and when belichick doesn't
reveal stuff to you
you think the worst you think oh there's
got to be something happen here right
and i think it really comes down to
football
i think it comes down to big receiver up
that they didn't believe he could get it
done and he was having during the course
of the week uh some physical sickness
problems he was in the hospital for a
few days i just don't think they thought
he was right
if they won the super bowl would we know
the story of why malcolm butler did not
play probably would have a better chance
but you know belichick dan he's not
going to reveal anything and it's funny
i tell people all the time well we'll
get it in the book nah you won't get it
but i respect him though glenn because
if i'm a player
he's not dishing on you and a lot of
these coaches you know they can be
saying something to somebody who says
something to somebody and then it gets
to the media
bill doesn't strike me as that guy and
like we still don't know how jimmy
garoppolo got traded do we
we do not but i think it's been
overplayed
where people say um and i think i can
say this with some confidence that it's
been overplayed when people say that bob
craft forced his hand to do it i think
he loved jimmy garoppolo i think bill
thought that jimmy garoppolo could be
the replacement for tom brady but he
also realized it was just bad timing the
timing didn't work tom brady was not
ready to expire and as it turns out
he wasn't ready to expire a year ago
when they separated from each other
we're seeing that now
what role do you think brady had
in jimmy garoppolo if any getting traded
i don't think he had much i really don't
i think you're starting to hear
a different tom brady right now i
noticed a different tom brady tom brady
is free to talk right now in tampa and i
think you would have heard a lot more
about some of that stuff if tom brady
had a role in it i think brady t when he
says the role i'm just the employee i go
and do my job i think that's what his
role was there i think he has a much
different role now in tampa bay he's got
a voice you know obviously aries listens
to him maybe gives him a lot of rope and
i think you're seeing
that being passed along to people like
aaron rodgers and how he views his
position in green bay now
do you have a go-to larry bird story
uh i have a bunch of uh go-to
uh larry bird stories because
uh he was pretty damn good i'll give you
the we're talking about the greatness of
larry bird and the difference of
athletes thinking about statistics we're
playing in salt lake city one night
larry bird has got a triple double he is
i think one assist
away from a quadruple double which as
you know is a rarity in in the nba
celtics are up by like 24 points or
whatever most athletes would say screw
it i'm going back out there on the floor
it was the end of the third quarter all
he had to do was come up for a minute of
the fourth quarter and he could have
picked up that additional assist most
athletes would sit there and say give it
to me larry bird said i'm done the
coaches said no no you got to go back in
here you want to assist a shy he goes
we're up by 24 points what are we doing
here and he said no i won't go in
but were you courtside when you were
doing play-by-play for the celtics like
could you hear
what was going on on the floor
yeah i was uh i was courtside because in
the road at home we were high above
courtside at the td garden you remember
uh johnny most and i worked with johnny
for for seven years the great
play-by-play voice of the celtics when
larry bird would check into a game in
the old days dan on the road johnny was
a chain smoke he lit himself on fire one
night and he got the cigarettes kept the
cigarettes underneath the table
underneath the desk when bird would
check into the game
he would drive johnny crazy he would
steal his cigarettes and he would take
him down to the official score and drop
him off there
wait so johnny moe set himself on fire
during a game twice
yeah twice so he would have he was a
chain smoker so he had two cigarettes
going he had one going in front of him
but that was going that cigarette was
gonna go out so he had to have a second
one ready to go so he would like two of
them the problem was he dropped one of
them on right on the crotch of his pants
polyester pants i may have and they went
up like in an oil blazing fire
uh i'm proud to know you congratulations
on a wonderful run and uh i hope you
keep in touch glenn thank you uh for all
you did for this show and uh certainly
what you did for the city of boston dan
thank you very much and i really
appreciate your support over the years
you've been great good friend thank you
glen ordway wei boston radio host for 34
years